good morning and welcome to the press
point on the start of the accession
negotiation process with albania and
north macedonia
president on the line you have the court
yes thank you very much dear prime
minister fjallah dear peter
prime minister rama yeah eddie
prime minister kovacevsky dimitar
what a historic moment
today
albania and north macedonia
are opening the accession negotiations
to the european union
and i'm so glad to be here with you
this is your success
is it it is your success and your
citizen success
you and your citizens you and your
paypal people have been working so hard
to get here
and you have shown so much
enduring commitment to our values
you've demonstrated resilience
you maintained faith in the accession
process
you strengthen the rule of law
you fought against corruption
you have free media
you have a vibrant civil society
you've done countless reforms
and you've modernized your economy
you've made all these changes not just
because they were necessary on your path
towards the european union
but above all because they are good for
your countries
and they are already delivering
a better quality of life for your people
we the european commission have
supported you all the way and we will
continue to do so
so let me briefly
reflect on three topics
first of all on the negotiations
right after the intergovernmental
conference today the commission and the
negotiation teams from albania and north
macedonia will start to work
the screening of the eu aqui will start
this is the first step in the process
the screening will enable
albania and north macedonia to get
familiar with the right and obligations
of our union
from treaties to legislation to
international agreements you name it and
we will proceed very quickly with that
my second point is
we will continue to get closer in key
areas
for instance albania will now join the
eu civil protection mechanism
we already started the discussion last
month
this will enhance albania's resilience
to natural disasters like floods or
wood fires or earthquakes
and member states know
as some fight terrible fires as we speak
right now in this very moment
that the european union is always there
to support when disasters
strike
north macedonia
will very soon negotiate with us the
frontex agreement
so it is about the deployment of
frantics to north macedonia
and this will strengthen our cooperation
in migration
and dimitar you can count on my support
to ensure
that the agreement is translated into
the macedonian language
no footnote
no asterisks on equal footing with all
24 european languages
and my third point is
that the benefits will accrue
as you will advance with the
negotiations
there will be a boost in investment
there will be
improved trade links there will be
closer collaboration in key areas like
for example energy or transport
you will maximize the use and the impact
of eu funding
and this means new jobs new business
opportunities
this is what your citizens have been
waiting for so long and have been
working for so hard and this is what
they deserve
finally
prime minister rama dear eddie
prime minister kovacevsky the dimitar
let me address you personally
you have shown
so much leadership
so much vision
you have shown strategic patience eddie
in abundance
and not only but most importantly in
these challenging times of russia's
brutal war
you have proven time and again
your attachment to european values as
true friends and true partners and i
want to personally thank you for that
prime minister fjalleda
congratulations
congratulations because the start of
negotiations of albania and north
macedonia is a major delivery
deliverable right at the beginning of
your czech presidency
it is building on the work of previous
presidencies and i know
you will play an important role to make
sure that this process advances swiftly
the people of albania and north
macedonia deserve it
and we will all stand to gain
when one day
we welcome albania and north macedonia
as full fledged members of our european
union
thank you
thank you very much and now prime
minister fiala the floor is yours
at the end dimitar ladies and gentlemen
on behalf of czech presidency of the
council of
the eu
i congratulate both your countries north
macedonia and albania
on this milestone
we all will be stronger for your clear
european choice which has been tested a
few times already
facing the russian aggression we highly
appreciate that you fully stand with the
eu common foreign policy and security
policy
in the europe of today
we must be united more than ever
czechia always supported a future new
membership of western balkans and will
remain so
we are honored that such a progress
takes part during our presidency however
we have to thank to the french
presidency for all their hard work and
dedication that led us to this historic
moment
the czech republic and whole central
europe know well the importance of the
eu integration for our democracy
security and development of our economy
the european union future is within you
your reach
i wish you the swiftest possible pass to
our european union family
thank you very much prime minister rama
the floor is yours
thank you uh we will have to speak
several times today so
i'd like
to start in this very morning with some
thanks
and of course
i
want to thank first and foremost
the president of the commission
ursula
who
knew
how to
[Music]
become
a german balkan
[Music]
presence in this uh building and to who
fights
for both to fight for
you and to fight for the western balkans
to fight for
all the member states
and to fight for us
aspiring to be members
and in the meantime i want to thank
another german lady who is not anymore
in business but
without her we would not have been here
today angela merkel and
she just had her birthday i want to wish
her
all the very very best
and in the meantime
it goes
uh
without saying that would not have been
here today without the extra effort
of the french president and the french
presidency
emmanuel
and
his team who worked tirelessly
especially during the nato summit
day and night i
could witness it
to get to the
final french proposal
which
opened the way to this
unblocking
of
an absurd
situation
so uh
very much thank you also to all the
albanian
people
who
never
gave up and never gave in
in the
dream to pursue
the
european path
and
thanks to whom
we could stand strong despite three very
very complicated years
where the refusals from the european
council on one hand
and the earthquake the pandemic the war
made a
perfect storm
but made us stronger
and of course i want to thank
wholeheartedly petter
who made the way from prague to here to
be with us today and to witness
the will of the czech presidency to keep
going
on pushing the
western balkan
full integration
we know that this is not
the beginning of the end is just the end
of the beginning
but
it is how it is and it's good
we need this
to continue build a strong
democratic
european
albania and a strong democratic
western and open balkan thank you
thank you very much and now prime
minister kovachevsky
distinguished prime minister peter fiala
distinguished prime minister reddy rama
just prior to the intergovernmental
conference opening the u membership
negotiations for north macedonia i would
like to express my sincere gratitude to
all our friends in the european union
for their support involvement and
commitment to the european integration
of north macedonia
their commitment was key so that we
today here in brussels
take the first step that will lead us to
full-fledged membership into the union
at the same time i avail my safe
myself of this opportunity to convey my
congratulations to the citizens of
albania to congratulate my colleague
eddie rama for starting the negotiations
for their country
i believe that this new beginning for
the region will mean prosperity and
progress
and when there is progress in one
country
there will stimulate the progress among
other neighbors
we will continue with the same dynamics
of regional cooperation
as a matter of fact we will continue as
we have been doing so far in an
excellent manner and then all
encompassing in the interest of our
citizens we work immediately within the
frames of our authentic initiatives and
process of cooperation
in this way we work for ourselves but
also we work for accelerating the
european union integration process
dear all
it is a great satisfaction that after 17
years today we are finally starting the
negotiations we are opening new
perspectives for our country and for the
citizens and steady but surely we are
joining the large european family
this has been our priority strategic
goal for decades
we recognize the european proposal that
we received
through white consultations as the best
possible solution that respects and
complies with the red lines from several
aspects and at the same time it finally
provides commencement of negotiations
this proposal defines the macedonian
language without any additions
explanations asterisks something that
was
of utmost import importance for us the
open doors for our macedonian language
to become one of the official languages
of the european union
something that i personally see as the
greatest achievement the greatest
success
in this way the macedonian language will
not only be protected but it will have
an enormous promotion because many
because many countries and cultures that
traditionally have no connections to the
macedonian language will be able to hear
it
at the same time our identity everything
that is authentic to our language
culture customs and traditions will
remain exactly that
authentically macedonian in the european
union and the union will be richer and
united in its diversity
north macedonia both from natural and
civilizational aspects belongs to the
european family
our place is in the european union we
have said many times so far that we are
a reliable partner
for the european union and for its
member states and we will continue to
work and function in this way
that is why i expect
that we will have a positive example of
fastest integration of a member state
into the european union just as we had
the fastest integration of a member
state into nato we are ready for the
european union
i am sincerely joyous together with the
citizens for today's welcome from the
european union
if we can predict a day by its beginning
then this will surely be an excellent
day a historic one a day that will make
us proud a day that will provide safe
secure and european future
thank you
and i wish
all of us
all of the success
thank you
thank you very much this brings our
press point to an end thank you
uh
you